okay so welcome to the top with the
mysterious title
this is joining work with James Bell the
raucous cone who's sitting over there
and copy so I want to talk about the
privacy blanket of the shuffle model so
do you just need to think about the
blanket full of excellence until I
define it define what it is just think a
blanket full of excellence so I mean
differential privacy we usually talk
about accuracy versus privacy and then
we like to study the limits of this but
but when we talk about the limits of the
years there's an extra dimension which
is the trust dimension is the dimension
of of which kind of assumptions we were
making about where the data lives and
how the mechanism is run so in this kind
of like trust axis we have two extremes
we have the central model and the local
model and and we know that moving from
central to loco has like some impact on
the accuracy so for example if we look
at the well studied questions of
approximating statistical queries where
every user contributes some value X I
from some domain X and we have some Q
that map's this into a real number
between 0 1 and what we want to do is
estimate the sum with privacy we know
that in the central model we can get
away with error constant error whereas
in the local model we need to like like
there's no way to escape like a square
root an error so I think this has like
destruct stark contrast has motivated
people to look into whether we could
find intermediate models where we don't
have the strong trust assumptions of the
central model where all the data is
handled to a curator that everyone
trusts and we let this curator apply Mac
and like differentially private
mechanisms to the data but something
that is not as pessimistic as the local
model where every one hand holds their
own data applies randomness locally and
then sends these messages to untrusted
aggregator or whatever which is what
makes like
as however the square root n so in this
setting there's one model that has come
up lately as something that interesting
to look at which is the shuffle model
that I'll define in a minute but
basically you have to think that this is
the local model with some additional
trust that we put into the transmission
channel that sends these messages to
whoever's gonna like run some
statistical analysis interesting in this
method
charrid all this uroclub paper they
showed that if you allow a square root n
messages you actually can get the same
accuracy as them at the central model
and and what we do in this paper is
focus more on the single message model
so we're only gonna like each user to
send one message and we show that in
this case we have upper and lower bounds
that show that the error is n to the one
sixth so this this model really sits in
between the center and the local model
okay so so what is the the shuffle model
so by the way this was like kind of
informally used in the encoding shuffle
and analyze paper the Prochnow paper by
beta at all and then there's these two
recent papers having son at all and
chavatal that have also studied variants
of this model i will define them all
that we used here and then I'll tell you
what the little differences are so we
can start from a picture that looks like
like the local model where we have n
users each of them holding a value X I
in some domain X and each of them wants
to apply is going to apply like a
randomized function mapping X to Y and
and getting y1 to yn and now instead of
sending these values directly to
somebody or or letting that could be
adversarial so we had to argue about the
privacy of over losing this topple Why
What Why Why am we're gonna apply a
random shuffle so we're gonna have a
trusted shuffler so we're going to
assume that that this part is trusted
like nobody can see what's going on
inside and and what this this little
building block is going to do
is gonna take these why eyes and it's
gonna apply a uniform random permutation
to this data and this is what is going
to be revealed to whoever's trying to
analyze this data for whatever purpose
and then when we think about the privacy
of this kind of protocols what we're
interested in showing is that if we
shuffle n copies of a given randomizer
under which constraint we can achieve
epsilon delta T P for the release of
this shuffle topple and and then to get
utility usually we post-process this
with some analyzer that for example
could like some of these messages or or
do like more fancy things so here is a
good point to highlight the differences
between this kind of shuffle model which
you could think of as being the
randomized and shuffle model with one
message so earnings and all what they do
is slightly different they say let's
shuffle the data first and apply the
randomizers afterwards so we can call
this the shuffle then randomized model
so in general this is a phase more
general and they also consider the case
where the randomizers could be adaptive
and and chair all consider it a slight
generalization of this which is still
randomized and shuffle but each user
might be using several randomizers and
in that case users submit several
[Music]
several wise but all these wise at the
end are going to get shuffled together
so you you don't get association between
the different wise from the same user is
that clear any questions so far
function that gets the wise depends on
the order of the wise this function here
yeah this function can depend on the
order yes but there's not much
information in in the order in from a
privacy point of view why do the
shuffling and not just as a turning a
sequence
to set its equivalent is the same thing
yeah it's like you could think that that
what would this block instead of doing
shuffle it turns that ball into a multi
set is equivalent yeah from a privacy
board
okay so what do we do in this paper or
we have to risk three results really so
the first two results are about the real
sum in this shuffle model so the setting
is is like the simplification of the
statistical query where each there's n
users each of them holds a number
between 0 and 1 and we want to estimate
the sum of these numbers and as I
already mentioned several showed that if
you you can get greater level accuracy
with come with square root n messages
communication squared n per user and
they also have a protocol which when you
send only one message you have constant
communication per user and you incur
error square root and so what we show is
that in this one message setting and to
the 1/6 is the right accuracy so we have
a protocol that has this sort of error
and a lower bound a matching lower bound
and you can achieve this with
logarithmic communication so that's our
first result the second result is a
general private simplification by
shuffling results and in here that the
type of questions that were asking are
so what is the privacy of these shuffle
mechanisms in terms for example of the
privacy of the individual local
randomizers that we are shuffling and
and in this setting this is the main one
of the main results of this our links
are called paper we're in the shuffle
then randomized setting where you can
even allow the randomizers to be
adaptive you get this sort of
amplification so if you're assuming that
the local randomizers are at 0 0 locally
differentially private then the
Epsilon's that you get a roughly epsilon
0 divided by n for constant epsilon
zeros and and what we do is we focus on
this kind of like different model where
we randomize first and then shuffle with
only one randomize and everyone is using
the same randomizer and in this case we
get the bound that is quite similar to
this one for amplification with the
difference that now instead of epsilon 0
here
we have first minimum between epsilon
zero and one that's what the wet
represents so this term only kicks in
when epsilon zero is rather small and
then for light epsilon this becomes the
one but then we have an e to the at
student 0 here and this bound applies
when epsilon 0 is roughly bounded by log
n so what that means is that this bound
also implies this one when epsilon 0 is
kind of constant you get like epsilon
there are like roughly 1 over log n I 1
over square root n but you can also have
another regime where when epsilon 0 is
roughly log n you end up with an
constant epsilon in the indicators yeah
so in in when you have only one
randomizer and there's no other
tivity it doesn't matter both settings
are equivalent when but but in other
cases it does matter so for example like
when intuition is that amplification
happens because there's anonymity right
you cannot track back messages to
individual users so if you have several
randomizers each of them could be
locally differentially private but they
could have a disjoint output space so in
this case randomizing and then shuffling
doesn't help at all you can track back
messages to users but if you do it the
other way around there's some
amplification happening so that's one of
the differences you could always say
that something happens equivalently
before and the question because in if
you only have one message it's
equivalent but but in my model you kind
of allows you one message and the other
model
there's only one randomizer and the
other it allows you to buy them
adapt yeah okay so these are the two
contributions the real summation
protocol and private simplification by
shuffling and now I'll get into details
first about the real summation protocol
which is a really simple protocol and
this after you see it so so the protocol
would what it does basically it says
well everyone's gonna have a number
between 0 & 1 which are real numbers and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
design a randomizer that is gonna map
this interval 0 1 into a discretization
of the 0 1 interval into k plus 1 bins
if you want or all of equal length and
this randomizer is gonna be quite simple
it's just a randomized response so when
a user submits X I with probability 1
minus gamma we're just gonna release a
randomized rounding of X I because we
have to do some rounding and we do it in
a randomized way to not introduce any
bias and with probability gamma we're
just gonna release something uniform in
this set okay so that's the the local
randomizer that that we use in our
protocol note that it depends on two
parameters gamma and K and the analyses
are gonna tell us how we should set
these two parameters to achieve this and
to the one-sixth error under
differential privacy and then the
post-processing the the the analyzer is
just three forward like you sum these
messages and you do bias which is a
standard structure
okay so how do we analyze the error of
this type of protocol is is quite easy
so first we just found the mean squared
error or the barians in this case of the
protocol here I ignore the shuffle
because for for accuracy doesn't matter
because I'm just doing some and you can
show that this body under mean squared
error is going to have two terms so one
term is gonna come from the rounding and
that term is gonna be n over K square
roughly and then you're gonna have
another term that comes from the noise
that you get which is a constant now s
times n with that you get with
probability gamma when you sample from
this uniform distribution in the in the
randomizer and and then once you have
this bound you say well how do I need to
set K and gamma to achieve epsilon Delta
V P and and this is this bound here that
tells you that gamma should be like K
over N epsilon squared and I'll show you
where this bound comes from next but
using this bound you can plug this value
of gamma here you can optimize for K and
you see that when you take K epsilon to
a 2/3 n to the one third this is the MSE
or variance that you get that has this n
to the one third turnips you don't
divided by four to the 4/3 and and then
you take square root of that and that's
where the end to the 1/6 comes from
okay so how do we analyze the privacy of
this type of protocol let's assume we
have six users and we're going to let
the sixth user change their data and and
the important observation here is that
this randomized response mechanism that
I defined that with some probability
just releases the value and with some
other probability just releases
something uniform you can write it in a
different way you can write it as a
mixture of with property one minus gamma
and I've done I've done nothing here you
release the value and otherwise you
release uniform random sample but now
when you look at the randomizers that
each user is is applying some of them
are going to sample from the green and
some of them are going to sample from
the right okay so when we want to
analyze the privacy of this protocol
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
couple these choices between green and
red on the two executions on the first n
minus one users then we're gonna look at
who is releasing they like the true data
and we're just gonna ignore them you can
think that we're gonna add them
afterwards and that would be just the
post-processing and then what we're
gonna say is that all these users that
sample from the uniform are providing a
privacy blanket under which the true
data of the end user that is changing
can hide okay so so that's kind of the
picture when we restrict when our
observation just to the end user plus
all the users that sample from from the
uniform and there's going to be roughly
gamma n of them then what we are really
observing after the shuffling if we
remove these guys it's just some uniform
samples from a uniform distribution and
one little ball that is hidden in this
beam that corresponds to the data of the
end user so we do that with a
neighboring dataset we're observing like
a similar random histogram
from a uniform distribution with one
ball hidden in another bin and then the
privacy analysis just tells us that we
need to make sure that we have few
enough bins and and enough samples from
the right distribution to make sure that
this person can hide its data so when
you do that analysis be a privacy laws
random variable you see that actually
the only bins that matter are the two
bins where like the balls of the of the
earth user false and and then in that
case that beam is gonna have the number
of random samples from the right he's
gonna follow a binomial with n minus 1
trials and probability of falling in
that bin gamma divided by K plus 1 and
in one case is going to be an extra ball
so if you try to bound this and make it
smaller than Delta so you can get
epsilon Delta differential privacy that
where you find out that gamma should be
like K over an epsilon squared
so now the that was the end of the group
of the upper bound the lower bounds the
lower bound I'm not going to prove
there's a proof sketch here you can read
but I think in the interest of time I'm
not gonna like go over it but basically
the lower bound says that if you have
any epsilon Delta V P one message
shuffle protocol for your summation
where there are any inputs in 0 1 and
Delta is less than 1/2 then any such
protocol must have mean squared error
which is at least n to the one third and
the minimum of these two privacy
parameters only for the case where you
randomized well when you have like one
message and when shuffler it doesn't
matter I think we can generalize it to
different shufflers and in that case
probably only when you afterwards but
I'm not 100% sure
okay yeah so and the proof basically
reduces this to the iid case and you
sure that any protocol can actually be
thought of as doing aggregation by
summation and randomizers that don't
have crazy output phases just zero one
and then you just design a distribution
that makes this large and and and yeah
so the intuition is that is that this
picture that we had with with the
histograms where there's like one ball
hidden and then like a random blanket on
top of it like like to get privacy you
must be doing this thing and therefore
if you're someone who releases their
true data so you stay close where you
are somebody else must incur large error
because they have to like provide
privacy for you and like cover you and
and and this is like the intuition so on
to the amplification by shuffling
results yes you're the P in the shuffle
model I don't think you can get much
better pure DP than like better pure DP
than what the local randomizer gives you
in the sense that you do need a delta to
get epsilon smaller than epsilon zero
okay and for the amplification yeah the
response is often are you asking or
making a yes we'll be matching when
epsilon small these lower bound applies
to any epsilon yes so imagine n but but
that's true so we have a and the epsilon
is no to the minus 4/3 in the upper
bound so there's there's a gap in the
epsilon strongly yeah but deanne is
tight
okay so that's the the kind of scary
bound that we prove for amplification by
shuffling and it basically applies to
shuffling and copies of any epsilon0 LDP
randomizer with blanket parameter gamma
that I haven't defined I'll define in
that in a minute and and and each like
the bounce shows that you can get
epsilon Delta DP for any epsilon Delta
satisfying this kind of scary thing
which you can do then some like
asymptotic gymnastics and and and use
the fact that we know how to bound gamma
for absolutely PK randomizers I'll do
that in the next slide and then break
over the bound that I gave you the
beginning assuming that epsilon 0 is
roughly less than log in house
okay so what is this blanket thing that
have been like mentioning several times
and haven't defined very well I guess so
the intuition is comes from this
analysis that I showed you before where
we were using the fact that randomize
response can be written as a mixture of
two distributions and and the important
observation here is that this red
distribution is independent of the input
data this red distribution is just
uniform so I I don't need to see what is
the input data here to sample from the
uniform and this guy is like completely
dependent on the data is a doubt on the
data so what we have is a blanket
decomposition theorem that says that any
local pure local BP randomizer will
admit the composition like this will
admit a decomposition and we can
actually show that this decomposition is
unique and maximal in some sense where
one of the components is independent of
the data so we can write this as this we
can say that this local randomizer are
on input X it always operates as follows
with probability gamma its samples from
some distribution Omega that is just a
distribution in the output space but has
never seen the data and with probability
one minus gamma what we apply is a
randomizer r-prime and we don't
know much about our prime but but it
doesn't matter what it would we can show
though is that this is the composition
that we obtain is the one that maximizes
this gamma in terms of like you cannot
get the composition like this with one
of the components ignores the data with
with the more with a larger camera and
that is important because gamma is is
related to the privacy in the sense that
every sample that we get from here is
going to help us provide privacy because
it's what generates this blanket that
covers for other people's data so we are
really interested in in finding a
decomposition where the gamma is
maximized no I'll show you the like I'll
show you here in a second I just want to
make one last remark which is that gamma
we know that for any epsilon 0 DP
randomizer is bounded between 1 and e to
the minus epsilon 0 so how do we get
this this blanket decomposition to
answer Ilyas question we can do it in
the following way
we can find the gamma first by
integrating over the output domain for
each point on the output domain we're
going to look at all the possible inputs
of our randomizer and we're going to
find the minimum of these output
probabilities across all randomizers and
and if you are in a in a continuous
output space this is easy densities and
you can integrate this and this is going
to give you the gamma and then what you
have is that the distribution of Omega
is just this minimum normalized by gamma
right so and I have some examples in the
next slide that hopefully illustrate
this but in the case of randomized
response you can easily see that if I
change like where this guy has the true
data to here for example and then I try
to find these minimums I'm gonna end up
with this uniform distribution that
after renormalizing gives me
so that's the Omega in that case this
plant will be sufficient to kill to meet
some condition on are sufficient for
privacy no because we're just gonna
ignore everyone that samples from our
prime you wouldn't be able to do that
with something that satisfies pure DP
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll talk about that
later you see okay so we know that that
every local DPI randomizer has has this
kind of decomposition so this is how the
gamma looks like for the randomized
response with K outputs and and privacy
parameter epsilon zero so remember that
that we know that this has to be between
1 and e to the minus epsilon 0 so for a
small case this is almost e to the minus
epsilon 0 if we have plus local
randomizer between 0 and 1 which
achieves epsilon zero LDP then the gamma
is e to the minus epsilon 0 house so
this is a bit further away from this but
actually even for other randomizers that
don't necessarily satisfy pure DP we can
have the same blanket decomposition we
can compute the gamma so for example we
did that for a Gaussian with input
between 0 and 1 and 10 variance Sigma
squared and and that's what you get so
this is this is a more general concept
than just something that applies to
local randomizer so I don't know I think
like we're still discovering with what
are the properties of this and I think
erin has already like some improvement
on this kind of diversity
and this is how this looks for for this
Laplace distribution right so we have
Laplace's with a fixed parameter B and
they're going to be centered between
minus 1/2 and 1/2 in this case so when
you put them all together and you try to
find this minimum that is what you need
to integrate to get the gamma you get
this gray region which in this case
happens to be another Laplace this is
not a general phenomenon it's just lucky
coincidence and and and here what I'm
plotting are for different values of the
input what are these the D are prime the
remaining day to depend on distribution
and you see that you can get like weird
shape support for 1/2 you get again a
Laplace but for things that are like for
example I guess minus 1/2 or minus 1 in
this case you get something that has 0
in in the large part of the zero power
output probability a large part of the
output space that is fine
so so how do we exploit this idea to
prove amplification by shuffling so the
proof basically follows a similar scheme
of the one that I showed you before just
for the case of randomize response but
but but at some point DBA is a little
bit so roughly the idea is that we are
again going to couple who samples from
the shuffle on on on both executions and
then we're gonna reveal the identity of
these people which you can think of just
applying joint convexity of differential
proxy on Delta and then we're going to
use this information to remove the users
who sample from our prime and we can
then add them later and you can think of
this is an instance of post-processing
[Music]
so how do we implement this in practice
goes through some specific random
variable that we for lack of a better
name honestly we call the private
simplification random variable which is
defined as follows so is a random
variable that is defined for any pair of
possible inputs X and X prime and
depends on the randomizer so we denote
it by L but probably that's not the best
annotation but the way you get it is you
take a sample from the blanket
distribution corresponding to the
mechanism R and you plug it into this
function that looks at first you take
the difference of observing the
probability of observing this Y from
input X on the randomizer R or minus e
to the epsilon only observing it from
the randomizer are on input X prime and
you divide that by the probability of
observing Y from the blanket itself so
it's a simple calculation to show that
this prime simplification random
variable has expectation 1 minus e to
the epsilon which is negative ok and and
that's going to be very important
because what we're going to do is we're
going to say is we're going to see that
what we need to bound is is the sum of
these random variables they're positive
part so if they're all negative the more
that we
the more that they're gonna concentrate
away from zero on the negative side and
that is where the amplification comes
from from a mathematical sense the other
important observation is that when the
mechanism is actually satisfies pure
local differential privacy with
parameter epsilon zero this private
simplification random variable is
bounded bounded by these two quantities
and that's also going to be useful when
we try to apply concentration because
what like concentrate abounded random
variables concentrate nicely and then
there's like the the bit of magic that
I'm not gonna discuss too much which is
this inequality that says that what you
should try to bound to get epsilon Delta
DP and I realized that's not how people
usually write it but you have to say for
all to demand the probability that this
shuffle mechanism is an e minus e to the
epsilon this is me so if I bound this
for all II by Delta then I'm cheating at
some Delta DP and and what we can show
is that this is upper bounded by this 1
minus 1 over gamma N and the expectation
of a sum of iid copies of this random
variable but a random number of them
that is binomial with n trials and
probability gamma and this plus denotes
maximum between a quantity and zero so
I'm only like counting this thing when
it when it exceeds zero and because the
expectation is this negative the the
bigger Annie's and the bigger gamma is
the less likely is that this thing will
exceed zero and now I'm going to count
it in this expectation and that's why
you can make this delta quite small
yes so the nice thing for me about this
proof is that you reduce this analysis
to just a concentration question and
then you have a ton of tools you can use
to want to bound the concentration of
that expectation of sum of iid random
variables so if you apply just a
standard huffing with these upper bounds
for upper and lower bound for L that
follow from the pure DP assumption on
the local randomizer that's what you get
but the advantage of this method is that
you can think that there are a lot of
variations you can implement on top of
this so here we achieve this and the
subsequent corollary by just plugging in
properties of L and gamma that hold for
any pure randomizer but you could
compute this exactly four different
randomizes like I showed you with the
gammas and when you do that you get like
bounds are specific to any randomizer
and generally like better than the
generic bound on top of this like
coughing gives you this scary expression
you can apply a more fancy concentration
or quality like bennett's it's going to
give you an expression even scarier but
the good thing is that you can also put
this in numerical solver say well this
is my epsilon zero this is my gamma this
is my n find me an epsilon that gives me
Delta less than something and you can
solve it numerically so like the
asymptotic bounds are very nice because
they give us intuitions but in practice
you can you can use whatever you want to
solve this and like put more complicated
concentration bounds in there so you
mentioned that for the Gaussian one
which the gaussian randomizer which does
not achieve pure both the DP you can
still do the blanket decomposition you
can do the blanket decomposition yes
security people pounding on video yes I
think you can I I think in general it
might be true that if your local
randomizer satisfy something like
concentrated differential privacy or
something where all the moments of the
privacy laws random variable go down
fast enough you might be able to argue
that these elves come from a family
that's gonna admit concentration like
like subduction or something like this
but yeah I mean I'm not sure if we're
gonna get something general it's gonna
be a dog so we we haven't so the
advantage of having this property that
you can plug different expressions for
Alan demanded that depend on your actual
randomizer or used other concentration
boundaries then you can do plots like
this and then explore in in practice
with what's happening right so here for
example I can fix absolute 0 to be 0.5
and see as I grow and how small epsilon
gets and we should be getting this
regime where epsilon is like epsilon
zero divided by square root n and and
you can do that for generic mechanisms
and here I'm comparing against the bound
inner links or at all which also applies
in this regime but obviously they didn't
optimize the constants so this is not a
strictly a fair comparison
but just to get you an idea of the gains
that you get from like being able to
plug this into numerical solvers and use
this kind of more like scary expressions
but there are like definitely tighter so
an another interesting here observation
here is that the orange or red I don't
know is the huffing bound and the green
is is the bandit.bound so like it starts
to get better at probably like 10 to the
to the 4 and and and the reason is
because Bennet like manages to take into
account information about the variant of
this else which we can also compute and
and but but in general the the constants
are slightly worse so like for this to
kick in you have to take
larger at least in the generic case
because then we can also like do this
same sort of comparisons so here for
example I'm using the hoeffding bound
and I'm comparing what I get with with
the generic bounds for gamma and al with
what I get when I use information about
the the local randomizer so I'm trying
randomize responds with 12 put with 100
outputs and Laplace and I mean here I'm
plotting something different I'm
plotting epsilon 0 which is how much
privacy like how big I can make the
epsilon 0 in the local randomizer and
still achieve 0.1 10 to the minus 6 DP
so we see that well like all the bumps
that take information of the mechanism
bit the generic that's not surprising
and then you can like start making like
more finer comparisons and see that well
randomize responds with to our scripts
is better in terms of amplification than
Laplace which is better than randomize
respond with Putin and you can start
making like I guess like more
fine-grained decisions if you're really
trying to design a protocol to to get
well I mean like a difference between I
don't know I kept 0 2 or epsilon 2 or
3.5 might make a big difference in your
accuracy and this is again the same type
of comparison but here like just for
specific mechanisms the difference
between huffing and Bennet and and and
again we see that when we use Bennet
things become better and and you can
also see that that the difference
between huffing and Bennet actually
depends on the mechanism so four
mechanisms like randomize respond
without put a hundred where where we
know that the variance of DL is very
small
Bennet does much better because of the
present
so that's that's Lucia off the talk I've
shown you matching upper and lower
bounds for the one message one
randomizer real summation shuffle model
so this bound is with error n to the
one-sixth and we can achieve this with
communication log n which thing is quite
nice
the lower bound in this is I think as
far as we know the first tied shuffle
native lower bound so previous lower
bounds in this model we're reductions
from lower bounds in the local model and
this is like shuffle native we don't go
through a lower bound in the local model
and then for prime simplification we
have this some general unflexible bound
that applies to randomized then shuffle
with one randomizer protocols and and
the analysis I don't think I mentioned
that but the you saw that the analysis
is relatively simple the previous
analysis that we know we're all going
through subsampling and and i know i
think this is nice property you have
like other tools to analyze this type of
[Applause]
no we haven't tried to get tight
constants through shuffling I asked the
true composition and I'm sampling no no
I would be really interested to see like
what you get and actually I would also
be interested to see if you can recover
this other regime of going from log and
local db2 to customer so that's possible
so we're bound for your
I'm not 100% sure because here what
would we show the way we show the lower
bound is that when you're dealing with
real summation actually like without
loss of generality you can restrict to
protocols where the aggregation is
actually a summation which I don't think
might be true in general so in other
words that this is a lower bound that is
very specific to summation it doesn't go
through general like hypothesis testing
reductions or things like this is very
specific to summation so I'm not sure
I just said just as a follow-up question
I mean for all of these results they all
go into epsilon greater than one it's
just it's not specifically explicitly
written out in our favor but I mean it's
there you can it will be worse it'll
what I think like three times Epsilon
okay e to the three times Epsilon hmm I
think maybe in if you go we're just this
is something maybe you'll get biceps or
something like this so you get you get
some worse dependence because of other
tools but yeah so you're talking about
the indigenous power here get a worse
power but all of them actual having
you'll just have to track what happens
when and so on okay and this routine
it's just doesn't look as nice one day
that were human letters all this is this
is this constant here you have this is 2
for epsilon less than 25 or something
yes so yeah yeah yeah this 1/2 is what
give the square root then and gives you
a constant epsilon but in terms of like
the error that you get in estimation for
estimation tasks they show a lot more
than a constant yeah today